I think is another way to spread
yourself like fashion you know like
music I think tattoos you know tell
something about who you are my first two
was when I was 12 I actually asked my
mom all a young mom or I got a tattoo
and she thought I was joking
yeah yeah I was okay was this like a
tribe tribal yeah but I covered it up
then if I had a son he wants to get a
tattoo even at 12 I would help him I'll
be with him like choosing the right a to
this one more like the first like big
one it was from here to here it's all
crazy mix it has a woman it has like a
dollar is how like poker cards you have
some Mike it's funny because when I go
out on the street I see people full a
touch of like wow that guy who has
tattoos and I'm like what I'm talking on
power I'm full of tattoos - Tigers are
my favorite animals
I have this Tiger here have tire here
and have another Tiger over here when I
went to Thailand I got the opportunity
to show a little bit of the culture and
watch a lot of Tigers and I just like I
fell in love with them how powerful is
more and you know I'm beautiful they are
I think about how will look if I take a
picture like this it comes like a fever
sometimes like sometimes just want to go
crazy and go like oh I want to get
twenty titles and then get them rock
abida
which means life real or reality here
this layout tat will meet it means
loyalty and my closest friends we had
the same tattoo here I just wanted to do
something different so this is the
inside of Mickey Mouse
how he really looks like you know this
call
[Music]
the most painful definitely the ribs
hurt so much like I was crying and this
one too because you know it's so thin
right here at the scheme so I rolled my
hand was like this and I got one here
back then the open airy bonnet a to be
hurt like crazy - I wouldn't a - if I
don't lovely runner yeah I loved it
bonus or once I love the static of
movement you know so to me they're just
amazing so I like to have like woman to
pose it yeah this girl is you know I
just want to Google our life I like
these girls you know I think her profile
it looks old though so she's right here
here more eyes woman then I got Virgin
Mary I got this girl here to have this
right here I got my sister Karolina it's
not like wheels present but I think she
loves her family familiar but just not
my family that my fans my people people
that support me and I did this one this
is all special because I did I did this
one suddenly Henty 12 years ago and now
we got a gloves mask on the hint I was
like hmm
we're one night I think it's all about
personality you know just do it because
you want to not because somebody think
is cool no like no pressure just do
whatever you want as long as you feel
happy you know and they her like crazy
you